can people stop killing dan so quick oh
dad i'm just so bad
damn i will guard you with my life this
next round thank you
you know what important thing is that
we've had fun if i am the opposite
i'm killing you oh good thing i'm a crew
mate then
it is dan that's so exciting but it
sucks for me because i absolutely
[ __ ] hate it
okay i could have killed drumsy just now
and i didn't i'm gonna kill ross
another event and i'm a vet
i'm and i'm a pop out and i'm gonna be
okay
and you're not muted you gotta mute
yourself i'm sorry
dan don't you think i would have if i
could have
i last saw ross in electrical alana was
the last person to walk in there when i
was leaving
good enough for me i don't know when
this happened
yeah wow yeah kind of upset along with
king voted out because i was trying to
kill dan that entire round
[Laughter]
listen all i'm saying is
i didn't think you'd find ross that boss
okay so
all right
oh no i just gotta hang out be a ghost
i really [ __ ] up i really didn't think
they'd find him
oh damn do it damn damn come on
dan you got it dan what are you doing
buddy you gotta kill people damn
come on you can do it fun you can't kill
two of them
make sure you don't do that don't do any
of that what's he what's his plan
what's his game what's he doing why is
he doing this
i don't understand what dad is doing and
what are you
you're clearly not doing tasks you know
that's the problem
you're clearly not [ __ ] doing tasks
because you're just hanging out
i'll do comms helping you as best i can
but
helping you as best i can this is
i think it was aaron i think it was
aaron guys
so first of all the cam the calms got
sabotage
then ann killed albert
mind you those aren't those aren't
giggles of happiness they're giggles of
like maniacal evil yeah that's
all the watch could happen dan was also
the last one the only one who skipped
last round two
wait dan what's your defense i'm gonna
defer i'm gonna uh
well i'm not gonna
[Laughter]
it was just so funny because like i was
trying to get
i was trying to get away from everyone
so i could kill someone but so many
people were trying to protect me that
they kept falling
i was following you when i was dead that
whole round just being like what you
doing buddy what's the plan here
is anybody gonna die jayden drumsy and i
were all stacked on one body then he
murdered albert and the three of us just
stared we didn't report we just stared
amazing
everything was going really well for a
while i don't know that it was i also
screwed you there i should have been a
better imposter mate
um but then like you screwed yourself
way worse than i ever could have
anticipated
the main issue was that he needed
bodyguards and he got three of them
yeah sean was right you can't trust
australians
did you did you bind mute to a key i've
got
i got toggle mute um and then on keybind
um i i don't know how to uh
do that last thing you said just click
the keyboard the key when you hover over
the keyboard it'll say edit keybind
yes and then click it and then it'll
start recording for a button and just
press whatever button you want it to be
and then click stop recording that's
genius
so you just press that button to mute
and then to un you unmute give it a go
give it a test dan give it a word
okay how's this
great you did it wrong perfect
great success what did you set it to
uh the the letter i so when you press
i it doesn't mute you i'm pressing it
now
do you okay was it perhaps the l key
you could also set it to mute or hold
some mute
now i've got it i've totally got it okay
cool you try it
i haven't done it yet okay okay
oh my god now you press it again
[Laughter]
you son of a [ __ ]
how y'all so speedy very speedy
frame where was everybody dancing
hey everyone okay
all right so i went i was in admin
and sean and i were pretty much together
the whole time i was an admin and then i
went down into storage
and uh yep it was some storage
by the by the gas can i don't know how
to tell you the name of the place
cinnamon because i don't know what it
was but ross you just passed me
where am i i'm doing the leaf thing oh
you're an o2
thank you appreciate it appreciate it so
like who's been in storage
asking for a friend damn it i mean me
and ethan but we've been
i've been in together the whole time
all right everybody keep your papers
peeled and uh keep your
uh keep your dicks wet or whatever i'm
mute
one okay there's two of you there's two
of you i think i'm good
i think i'm good i think sean might have
been out here to kill me
don't you [ __ ] backtrack bro all
right i gotta go to admin
let's go i think sean's probably maybe
okay based on
caught your red-handed aaron
electrical the the lights went out i
turned him back on
and then drumsy came in aaron came in
right behind me
or right behind aaron uh wait no drumsy
came in
aaron came in right behind drumsy i left
and then i went back
up i saw aaron kill drumsy and then he
vented
dan are you the imposter i don't know
i trust him well it couldn't have been
atlanta for this kill because she was in
the hallway
well because it was aaron is why that's
that's very true too
actually yes
okay i'm just gonna do this task right
here i'm just gonna do my task
oh the imposters still have full
visibility though huh
how is nobody dead uh i just sort of
don't buy it
unless they're really like maybe the
other one is dan
and he's really bad
i feel like that would also make sense
one two three four five
[Music]
hello i thought it was maybe time
somebody did that yeah
yeah i've called this one today because
we know that aaron uh is deceased
because
he's an imposter and i called him out uh
now i would like to toss a question to
dan dan what have you been doing this
round
i've been running around i can actually
vouch for that yeah we saw him run past
multiple times
yeah motorists can run around what tasks
have you been doing dan
i saw i saw dan vent why did you just
mention this now
because do you remember that dan venting
is like expressing my feelings in a
long way yes yes how are you feeling dan
i'm all right yeah i'll be honest that
was a shot in the dark i was just hoping
he'd say oh darn it you got me
oh i bought a fan based on that no
well oh fun okay well i'm
all right dan says it's ross
[Music]
[Laughter]
i knew i probably wasn't doing well when
ali texted me the map on my phone
[Laughter]
crewmate okay let's go let's go
let's go damn you
oh yeah thank you
[Laughter]
it can't be dan again right surely right
i just so badly don't
want it to be dan is part of my problem
um he's too pure and
i don't like it okay let's go storage
let's go storage how is nobody dead yet
really like not a single dead person
nobody's dead
hmm oh oh someone left a drumsy
in admin aaron was kind of hovering
around
and then alana went down i think yeah i
did shields
which actually also went that direction
drumsy was on shields
right before me yeah so i will say
and then i went to electrical and then i
ran up to uh security and that's when i
went in
well you know what nobody asked you ross
ross acting kind of suss right now okay
around i also think aaron is acting
weird with his music yeah i think that's
awesome
nonsense okay ross i stand with you
thank you thank you jayden i i also
stand with you
yeah well i prefer standing by myself so
that's fine
okay let's go to admin and
make sure that we do tasks
you guys i don't like to stack you [ __ ]
does in theory mean i won't die though
okay please don't kill me please please
don't
kill me please don't kill me aaron
what are you doing erin aaron what are
you okay
i think that kind of clears aaron maybe
a bit i think
oh where we have to go good
someone killed him right on oxygen okay
so it's not
me alana shawn or ross have you cleared
ross
i know it's not you oh wait no it's not
russ i was just
so sean and i were kind of following
each other and then alana was
so unless it's not well out but two
people are dead actually
yeah if you are to be believed then it's
ross and dan in my opinion
why isn't it you yeah why isn't it i
didn't do it
a compelling argument all right i want
everyone to know that the good job that
i've been doing on this ship as a crew
member okay okay
okay curious remember the beautiful menu
that they have
and i had to upload it to admin so that
everyone can get it on their
little tablets and know what's for lunch
today oh my god thank you
you're welcome today then i i well i
didn't read it i just saw the truth
so it was poison it's aaron well i'm
actually celebrating nobody's putting
the finger on dan i haven't seen dan
once this whole [ __ ] game and
you know what i haven't either he's a
dog because he's a nice puppy dog and i
don't yeah i don't think i will ever put
the blame on dan unless he murders
someone in front of me again
i wanted him to actually kill me last
time oh
oh my gosh what
you guys what the [ __ ] i don't i don't
know why
aaron got done there i don't understand
why iron did wrong at all
let's go [ __ ] knew it ross i knew it
yeah what did i [ __ ] say
remember when aaron accidentally picked
the imposter
again i stumble ass backwards into
victory
damn become the imposter like every
round i
hate it i do not like the pressure i
didn't choose the thug life the thug
life chose me